So for the last couple of days, every few
hours, we have like five additional percent
scent
of the Donald Trump, Joe Biden, Ukraine withholding
aid fiasco confirmed and we're closer and
closer to just being able to say the entire
story as reported is true.
Now, to reset the story, what we're talking
about here is a report that Donald Trump ordered
Ukraine to smear Joe Biden.
If they want $250 million in military aid
plus some other rate at now it appears, uh,
and otherwise they don't get it.
And this was allegedly discussed during a
phone call between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president back in July.
We now know that Rudy Giuliani was pulled
in to work on this and we're talking about
corruption, bribery, the term collusion is
being thrown around.
I mean really beyond the pale to such a degree
that even American law may be ill equipped
to deal with what it is that the president
is doing here.
And the initial reaction from Donald Trump
was, everything's fine.
Like not necessarily denying the particular
elements of the story, but saying we had a
totally normal, normal phone call.
Everything's fine.
The story is bogus, it's all fake news, et
cetera.
But slowly and over the period of a couple
of days, we get confirmation of more and more
elements of the story.
Donald Trump admitting sort of blurting out
really that the topic of Joe Biden did come
up during the July phone call with the Ukrainian
president, Donald Trump, admitting that Joe
Biden being supposedly corrupt, was a topic
of conversation during the phone call.
Donald Trump admits I did want Rudy Giuliani
involved in this entire thing.
Generally, Rudy Giuliani with Chris Cuomo
on CNN admitting he did ask the Ukrainians
to quote, investigate Joe Biden's.
So slowly but surely they deny the whole story,
but then admit to almost every single one
of the component parts.
Well, now we have a really big piece of this,
which is that the Washington post is broken.
The story that indeed just days before the
July phone call between Donald Trump and the
Ukrainian president, Donald Trump ordered
military aid be withheld from Ukraine.
Donald Trump told his acting chief of staff,
Mick Mulvaney, there's still no permanent
chief of staff by the way, hold back the money
just a few days before the phone call.
According to three senior administration officials,
this was then relayed to the state department
and to the Pentagon.
Now of course they're going to come up with,
and I think they already have actually some
innocuous benign reason for why the money
was ordered with held something like, Oh,
Trump thinks there may be better uses for
the money or something like that, but once
again, another element of the story is confirmed
that the timing of the money, if not the justification
for the money being withheld, the timing of
the money being withheld lines up perfectly
with the phone call during which Donald Trump
asked Ukraine to smear Joe Biden.
The story is accurate guys, the story is real.
The story is true and this is a of four people
who are now waiting for consequences to this.
Let me cut to the end of the story.
There are not going to be consequences for
this.
Here's how it's going to go.
Eventually pressure will build for the transcript
of the phone call with the Ukrainian president
to be released.
Remember that the white house has a history
of editing transcripts.
When Donald Trump slips up and says something
stupid, so eventually the white house will
acquiesce or at least pretend to be acquiescing
and they will release a transcript and it
will either be incomplete or it won't show
an explicit quid pro quo.
Only an implied one and Republicans will say,
see, there's nothing to see here.
Even if there have been other conversations
about this, which I'm sure there have been,
then Democrats will have to come back and
say, well listen, the quid pro quo doesn't
have to be explicit, but it will be just muddled
enough that nothing will happen.
And Donald Trump will claim that it's just
another witch hunt.
The whistleblower complaint, which is at the
heart of this entire thing will be suppressed
and then it'll be November of 2020 and people
will be voting without Donald Trump having
ever had to suffer any consequences as a result
of this, and I want to remind you this is,
this is like the maybe the most important
thing.
The problem here is not the specifics of the
phone call transcript.
The white house is suppressing a whistleblower
complaint as well as the information in that
complaint.
That's the main story.
It's not Biden, although we will debunk the
conspiracy theory around Biden a little bit
later in the show.
It's not necessarily the transcript of this
one phone call because if this is how Donald
Trump is dealing with Ukraine, there is obviously
much more than just this one phone call that
led up to this request for from Ukraine to
Ukraine to smear Joe Biden.
The story here is the suppression of the whistleblower,
but the Trump cronies are going to successfully
narrow all of this to being about the content
of one call and the transcript of that one
call.
And by the way, in the context of the democratic
primary, this all probably helps Joe Biden
in the polls.
I would not be surprised if next week we start
seeing polls just renewing Joe Biden's position
at the top and cutting the downward momentum
that he's been experiencing.
Elizabeth Warren has had big momentum in the
last couple of months, but I predict that
all of this helps to maintain Joe Biden in
a solid lead in the primary.
We'll we'll see when we get new polling next
week.